hi there known genius elon musk here
full of good ideas that always work out
tell me wouldn't it be epic to live on a
mars colony live on the red frontier
what could be more epic reddit 420 kian
reef than that but just what is a mars
colony well it's a colony on mars it's
the reason why spacex exists in the
first place and they are already working
on it the establishment of the colony
itself together with the lunar base is
scheduled for 2022 as announced in 2017.
following five years of feverish work
the project is already in the cgi
rendering stage the colony will feature
cool surface domes a ton of solar panels
and the remote controlled self-destruct
mechanism in case colonists tried to
unionize join us on this exciting
suicide mission which doesn't have any
practical goals or justifications beyond
the law or on mars yeah a mars colony is
an extremely stupid and dangerous idea
and it will be for the foreseeable
future and i'm here to explain why if
you are excited about the mars colony
chances are it's because of elon musk
people like elon musk who pay millions
of dollars to market themselves as
real-life tony starks have managed to
convince a lot of people that our level
of technology is far more advanced than
it actually is i call this the marvel
effect since their movies do the exact
same thing don't tell me that when you
first saw the shield helicarrier you
didn't think it was kinda sorta possible
to build in real life with our existing
technology and don't get me wrong we
have come a long way in terms of what we
can accomplish but colonizing mars let
alone [ __ ] terraforming is still out
of our reach but even if we had the
technology to reliably colonize mars
right now doing so still wouldn't make a
lack of sense and so throughout the
video we'll be considering the following
points the logistics of getting to mars
the potential justifications for economy
the practical problems of living on mars
the psychological effects on colonists
[ __ ] terraforming better alternatives
to mars and a mystery point code name
absolute train wreck and i find the
psychological effect especially
concerning your mental health and mars
aren't exactly a match made in heaven
exercising mental hygiene is hard enough
on earth but thankfully fabulous is an
app that can help you do just that the
sponsor of today's video fabulous is
your digital coach a happiness trainer
so to speak it's the number one
self-care app out there to help you
build better habits and achieve your
goals fabulous really helped me maintain
my mental health after reading about ela
musk's mars related ideas based on
behavioral science it helps you develop
great healthy habits and routines backed
up by science real science for a
healthier more productive and fulfilling
lifestyle the app will help you create
your own rituals these small steps that
lead to big changes the two main ways to
use the app or habit tracking and
dedicated programs in heavy tracking you
can choose from 100 plus recommended
habits or you can create your own
fabulous then lets you build these
habits with gentle reminders and content
based on behavioral science dedicated
programs help you achieve your
well-being goals over the course of
several weeks the new habits you pick up
can be added to your daily routine if
you so choose the app even sends you
nice letters weekly reviews and monthly
self-care checklists and how nice is
that with the premium version you can
build and improve and unlimited number
of habits in your routines and you have
access to all programs and exercises
start building your ideal daily routine
the first 500 people who click the link
will get 25 of their fabulous
subscription thank you for checking out
fabulous ads like this help support what
i do and now back to the video
let's get started problem number one the
logistics of getting there the average
distance between earth and mars is about
230 million kilometers it's average
because the distance constantly varies
earth and mars don't orbit the sun at
the same speed so you can just launch a
spacecraft fully nearly you have to time
it right in a so-called launch window so
the trip is as short as possible this
launch window is about 30 days occurring
every 26 months launching in this window
means that the trip to mars will only
take seven to nine months the logistical
implications of this are of course
pretty severe if a resupply mission
fails for whatever reason you're
potentially looking at a more than two
year delay of supplies not to mention
the risk of something going wrong during
a landing now recently the rate of
failure for mars missions seems to be
lower but compared to a mars colony
those are very simple missions where you
aren't trying to land years worth of
supplies or actual colonists for me this
would mean sending twice or even three
times the amount of needed supplies at
the same time for a mars colony with
separate transportation just in case one
or even two of them crash land or
something of course cargo can stay in
space for longer so i can imagine you
could also pre-launch a whole lot of
cargo ships even outside of the launch
window in a way that they would reach
mars at predetermined times but this is
still suboptimal unmanned missions can
afford risk of failure manned missions
cannot nothing can go wrong which means
lots of fail saves lots of backup
consequently the costs will be
horrendous and for what let's take a
look at the potential justifications for
a mars colony and the problem is there
are none discounting vagaries like it's
for science or the atiq lower on mars
currently we have absolutely no reason
to be there in person there are no
valuables to extract in large quantities
but even if there were shipping them
back to earth would make it the most
unprofitable venture in human history in
terms of science there is not much
humans could do that rovers can't mars
is a rock desert there is not much
opportunity to be productive now
overpopulation and escaping climate
change are reasons people sometimes
bring up in favor of colonizing mars and
both are rather stupid first off with
appropriate planning and technology
earth can support vastly more people
overpopulation is only a problem with
our current wasteful space use and
inefficient food production if we fixed
those with the magic of science
overpopulation would stop being a
problem if you expanded the population
the city of the netherlands to the
planet its entire land surface you could
theoretically house 75 billion people or
even if we take half of that that's
still 38 billion about 5 times the
earth's current population but if you
insist on decreasing the earth's
population through a mars colony
realistically you'll have decreased it
by about 50 and it only costs you 40
billion dollars per person so if you
want to affect the overpopulation
problem instead of assembling a
colonization mission to mars you would
achieve more by bulk ordering condoms
and handing them out on a street corner
for free as for climate change people
including elon musk make it sound like
mars would be humanity's plan b in case
of a climate disaster on earth but by
humanity elon actually means the select
few aka the top one percent what you
thought you would be on the evacuation
rocket even assuming we can put together
a city-sized functional colony on mars
and we can evacuate say a million people
via rockets those seats will be
distributed based on leverage you will
be on the rocket if you can buy lobby or
otherwise force your way onto it and
while there are only a few thousand
billionaires out there there are plenty
of millionaires to go around more than
willing to escape the planet in case of
a global catastrophe humanity's
so-called plan b in case of a climate
disaster on earth would just be a rescue
operation for the planet's ruling class
nothing more but even if the ruling
class or anyone else made it there soon
the harsh reality would start setting in
namely the problems with living on mars
mars is a kind of orange hell for human
beings with a wide range of dying
opportunities available to you martian
atmospheric pressure is less than one
percent that of earth which means a very
thin atmosphere which means harmful
solar radiation and micrometeorites tiny
stones flying like bullets aimed at
buildings and your pressure suits visor
moreover on earth the coldest
temperature ever recorded was minus 89
celsius measured in the arctic on mars
temperatures often go below -120 even if
you have a warm period the thin
atmosphere just won't retain any heat
mers's outer core is also frozen solid
meaning no dynamo effect meaning no
magnetic shield meaning hazardous levels
of cosmic radiation even if you dig in
to avoid said radiation colonists will
be exposed to higher than average rates
for the rest of their lives that means
after some years rates of cancer will be
through the roof in addition gravity is
one-third of that of earth so even
though you would be able to lift heavy
things and bound around thanks for
tapiylan there's no telling what health
problems low gravity would cause the
longest stay in microgravity so far is
less than a year beyond that we can only
extrapolate how would the low gravity of
mars affect pregnancies or your
cardiovascular system who wants to be
the first lucky one to find out in light
of these dangers as far as i can tell
pretty cgi and sleek domes on the
martian surface are complete [ __ ]
unless you're planning on dying but if
you aren't your only option is to dig in
and live the rest of your life in a
martian underground bunker only coming
out occasionally when there isn't a
solar flare blanketing the surface with
dangerous levels of radiation the wide
variety of lethal dangers plus being
crammed together in a small underground
bunker with dozens of others for the
rest of your life will surely do wonders
for your mental health by the way and
let's talk about that these
psychological effects on colonists now
some people might say we cannot tell for
certain what the mental health effects
on the colonists would be because there
is simply no such precedent and they
would be wrong to say that we absolutely
have precedent and it's not looking too
good consider this quartz article titled
it's completely ridiculous to think that
humans could live on mars in this
article there's a useful snippet we will
now read together despite having a
completely breathable atmosphere and
plenty of fresh water antarctica has no
permanent residence nobody wants to live
there scientists who work at arctic
bases suffer from a mental health
disorder called winter over syndrome
characterized by symptoms such as
depression irritability aggressive
behavior insomnia memory deficits and
the occurrence of mild few states known
as the antarctic stair since it must be
a bit like living with a colony of
zombies it's no wonder that they want to
stay drunk all winter imagine this but
without the atmosphere outside plus all
the deadly hazards the thought that you
won't be going home ever again and the
fact that your lives are constantly on a
knife's edge because if your life
support systems fail there won't be any
rescue operations in such conditions all
colonists would be varying degrees of
insane after a month if just one of them
starts a fire sabotages the life support
system or opens the airlock everyone
will be dead now these mental health
problems are caused by mars being mars a
hazardous rock desert but what if we
could change that turn this dead planet
into earth 2.0
so let's talk about [ __ ] terraforming
okay first off let's get the obvious out
of the way as things currently stand
terraforming mars is [ __ ] magic we do
not have the resources or technology to
terraform a planet despite what elon
musk would want you to believe that's
more of that marvel effect i guess from
the spacex website it's a little cold
but we can warm it up presumably elon
will press the magic big brain science
button and mars will just get warmer the
number one thing you would need to do on
mars is to create an atmosphere but
according to nasa if you combine all
sources of greenhouse gases on mars you
would end up with an atmosphere 6.9 that
of earth 93.1 short of your goal nuking
the martian ice caps as suggested by
countless reddit and twitter experts
would net you 1.2 percent of earth's
atmosphere without an earth-like
atmosphere there is not much else you
can do and this would only be the first
hurdle to overcome terraforming is
something we just don't have the
technology or resources for even with
our current level of advancement
terraforming to us is like traffic
engineering to elon musk or basic
empathy for his fellow human beings or
not harassing employees sexually but if
that's the case what else should we do
let's look at some of the better
alternatives to mars first off a simple
alternative for all the enthusiasts out
there if you want to try out what it
would be like to live on a mars colony
get together with your enthusiast
friends and crowdfund a trip to
antarctica that should curb all your
enthusiasm within a few months but
suppose we are really serious about
colonization and why not but i think
it's a good idea so why not create a
colony on the moon first the moon has
about zero percent atmosphere compared
to mars is 0.6 so as far as you're
concerned they're essentially the same
you'll have a much nicer view of space
and travel time is only 3 days instead
of 7 to 9 months if something goes wrong
you can go back to earth or at least
have a panic module able to sustain you
until help arrives on the moon your
internet latency is only 2.5 seconds
instead of half an hour and you don't
have to deal with the soul-crushing
realization that you'll never see your
friends and family again having a
permanent base on the moon could also
have actual justifications like an
observatory complex free of atmospheric
interference or a spaceport that could
take advantage of the lower gravity or
space tourism facilities for rich
[ __ ] or a massive solar panel
installation that can beam back power to
earth and so on some of these ideas are
still highly theoretical others are more
feasible but there is a good chance
we'll be seeing at least one of them
becoming reality within our lifetime but
what if you just can't let this whole
mars business go if a moon colony isn't
enough for you you also want to
terraform well i have good news there is
a great opportunity for you to satisfy
your scientism-oriented urges planet
earth is a great candidate for
terraforming there are vast areas on
this planet that are unsuitable for
large-scale human habitat how about we
practice by terraforming the sahara
desert and also making sure we don't
kill the amazon rainforest in the
process that would be a great first step
and it would benefit most of everyone
but that doesn't sound sci-fi enough so
elon musk talking about mars because
that's how you maintain the tesla stock
bubble so as we can see mars colony
planes are somewhere between complete
absurdity and stock manipulation but
there is one last part of this video the
mystery segment promised early on one
last point to hammer home the true
extent of the absurdity of the agitation
around colonizing mars we need to talk
about the lowest common denominator on
par with nigerian prince email scams and
low effort nfds mars one holy [ __ ] and
just what is mars one the
project was announced in 2012 the goal
to establish a permanent colony in mars
by 2025 with volunteers who get a
one-way ticket and will live out the
rest of their lives on the planet the
project was headed by a guy named bas
lansdorp and no that text box wasn't me
i took this picture straight from the
official mars one twitter wow i remember
when other serious organizations like
nasa used ms paint for their promo
material now you might be asking who in
the name of jesus rotary christ would
sign up for this and the answer is
people who either have nothing to fear
or nothing to lose usually the latter
200 000 people to be precise 100 of whom
made it to the shortlist wife threatens
divorce after her husband is considered
for a one-way trip to space there's only
a slim chance of mr sullivan being
selected to live on mars as just 24
people will be chosen but his wife said
he did not ask her opinion before
completing the application form and said
that she could not contemplate leaving
her children however mr sullivan says he
loves his family more than mars but also
wants to be the first to live on the red
planet and make a name for himself wow
that's a that's one way to get a divorce
i guess i'm not going to show any names
or faces but looking through the list of
applicants their faces don't exactly
scream balanced happy life and healthy
psychology now as for the mission
timeline of mars one well you can find
official but completely contradictory
information online the dates are just
all over the place go figure i'll just
use the wikipedia page and one of their
official promotion videos 2014 drafting
mission concept studies requesting
proposals from aerospace companies proof
of concept for key technologies required
2015 reducing applicant pool to 40. the
candidate pool was reduced to 100 okay
in 2016 the first comes satellite and
lander to demonstrate key technologies
one initial concept study by lockheed
martin lander and survey satellite
technology orbiter not funded nor
designed 2020 settlement components are
set up on mars 2022 crew departure from
earth and the first colonists would have
arrived in 2023 with the second crew
arriving by 2025 and by 2031 the colony
would reach 20 colonists one of the
participants though has a story to tell
former nasa researcher joseph roach
signed up for selection to help further
popularize space science to his surprise
he ended up on the top 100 shortlist out
of 200 000 applicants the 200 000 figure
was a lie worse according to roche some
of the leading contenders had simply
bought their way into their positions
and were being encouraged to donate
appearance fees to mars one after
passing each filter applicants received
points the amounts were completely
arbitrary and applicants could get
additional points by buying mars one
merchandise and through gifts and
donations otherwise roche despite being
on the top 100 list of prospective mars
colonists never met anyone from mars one
in person the original plan was to
conduct interviews at set locations and
be tested for several days which then
got changed into a 10 minute skype call
medical examination for colonizing mars
had to be done by each applicant on
their own at their local doctor
otherwise applicants had to fill out an
online test and record a short video
about themselves which they had to
upload to the mars one website the skype
interview came after during which mars
one's chief medical officer quizzed you
with questions from literature about
mars and the mission that mars one had
provided to all the applicants it's some
very serious selection process you got
there but for me personally the absolute
best part of mars one is how financing
was envisioned so how was it envisioned
well of course through a reality tv show
what yes this was the actual plan for
funding televising the application
process and then the colonists
day-to-day lives on mars cool so besides
the overwhelming stress and
psychological pressure of living on mars
with 19 others in a confined space
people also have to be on camera
constantly to shoot a reality tv show to
gain funding on which their survival
depends no pressure and i'm sure nothing
could ever go wrong with that you know
filming people under extreme
psychological pressure with
deteriorating mental health it's day 80
of the live on mars reality show brought
to you by mars 1 over here we have john
writing a manifesto on the wall which
appears to be his own feces having done
intense research into makeshift
ballistic weapons in the hallway julie
strangling maria in a fit of primal
animalistic rage james is blackout drunk
for the 75th consecutive day robert is
hanging from the ceiling
so where is mars one now i'm sure
they're working hard to the company went
bankrupt in 2019. well that's uh that's
uh not unexpected uh humanity's hopes of
colonizing planets have been dashed by
this company that planned on colonizing
mars through a reality tv show god damn
this was stupid anyway so this was my
video about a mers colony and why it's a
stupid idea for the time being at least
and i thank you for watching and don't
forget to like and subscribe and i have
a patreon if you want to support me
monetarily making this sort of content
and i'll be seeing you next time